Orton's imagination library to introduce
you to some wonderful authors who will
share their stories with us miss Parkins
work through her imagination library is
awe-inspiring she and her team have
given away over a hundred million books
to help encourage young readers like you
across the world here at the Library of
Congress we share that passion for
developing young leaders and we know
that the best way to encourage people
like you to read is to make reading fun
so that's what we're here to do I hope
you enjoyed today's storytime even more
I hope you keep reading at home and
having fun today you will warm up by
singing some songs touching your toes
and then get comfortable and get ready
to hear stories now let's get started
the Library of Congress so exciting so
we're gonna start with our Hello song
and a little bit of signing let me show
you hello you do a salute hello okay
hello and then friends you're going to
link your index finger one way and then
the other way okay
friends friends okay hello friends so
we'll do that three times and then it's
time so you're going to touch your
imaginary watch and then to say hello
okay and the tune is goodnight ladies
la Lala la Lala la la la la okay here we
go
hello friends hello friends hello
friends it's time to say hello one more
time hello friends hello friends hello
friends it's time to say hello good job
okay so let's do our usual warm-up open
shut them
okay here we go open shut them open shut
them give a little oh damn open shut put
them in your lap creep them crawl them
creep them crawl them right up to your
TV chichi open wide your little mouth
baby one more time oh then you shut them
open shut them give a little back Oh
baby shut them open shut them put them
in your lap creep them crawl them creep
them crawl them right up to your chin
okay we'd like to welcome Rachel Isadora
and her daughter up to read the first
book I just which we're doing this one
first hi
come up Holly WestEd here you can sit
there what's in here look at all the
people who's with her so welcome
everybody we're gonna read this book
first my mic work you two move and
everyone here should know I have to yell
okay this is this book is called I just
want to say good night
everyone see wanna go down
and it's by the writer of this book is
Rachel Isadora who is this lady right
here my mother she's my mom here's the
first page Oh
on the African felt there is a village
as the Sun sets parents tell their
children it's time for bed lalla greets
her papa who has been fishing who you
caught a big one she says yes it was a
good day Papa says to Lala
it's time for bed Papa tells Lola I just
want to say goodnight to the fish Lala
says come Lala mama says I just want to
say goodnight to the cat Lala says does
anyone have a cat know who you have a
cat anyone else have a cat oh back there
anybody else have a cat not up we got
him already
it's getting late mama calls I just want
to say goodnight to the bird
Lala says anybody the bird does anyone
have a bird no no birds who likes birds
you like birds
everybody likes birds you do Lala it's
time to go I just want to say goodnight
to the goat why Allah says yes what they
have boots
does anybody have a goat
he has a goat has anybody seen a goat
yes
oh here's a good one it's time to go to
sleep mama says I just want to say good
night to the monkey Wawa says all right
whoo does anybody have a monkey yeah no
are you sure are you sure are you
positive you saw a monkey Wow come now
mama says I just want to take a night to
the church has anybody seen a chicken
yeah
what do you know what they sound like do
you know what sound they make no do they
go trip
a rooster oh there you go Oh Lala mama
says I just want to say good night to
the little ant Lalo says does everybody
know what ant are little bugs
I'm just not ready to go to sleep Lalo
says to her dog who has a dog yes good
job you have a dog too and a cat you're
so lucky
does anybody else have a dog a doggie
you have a dog you have a doggie too who
loves their doggies
you do let's go now llama says yes yes I
am coming I just want to say goodnight
to the rock Lalo says who's that anyone
have a pet rock
lalla gets into bed
sweet dreams mama says goodnight mama
says Lola
everybody say goodnight to Lola
goodnight Lola wait she says I just want
to say goodnight to my book who who has
a book at home you do you do who else
has a book you you definitely have a
book you do how many you have five oh my
god do they all not want to go to bed
like well ago you should ask them no no
you see good night moon Lalo whispers
and smiles everybody say good night moon
and here's the last page this is the end
of this book good job everybody's got
lots of animals don't they and what's
the color you see most in it pink right
pink
likes pink alright so now we're going to
do a finger play about a bird and this
is from a book in the library collection
that was published in 1915 and it's
called mother Goose finger plays by
Irene Margaret Cullison 1915 so this is
called little robin redbreast so we're
going to make a Robin so take your hand
and fold in your inner fingers and
there's your Robin so that's his head
and that's a tail and then your other
hand is going to be a fence or they call
it a rail okay so little robin redbreast
and then he's going to sit on the rail
he's going to wiggle his head and then
his tail okay and the tune goes
oh I've forgotten the two little robin
redbreast side up on the rail little
knot oh boy little motto went ahead and
waggle went his tail little robin
redbreast
sat upon a rail little Nardo went his
head and waggle went his tail one more
time little robin redbreast
sat upon a real little Nardo went his
head and waggle went his tail alright so
now we're gonna do another one from that
same book and i think you know it it's a
little bit different pat-a-cake
pat-a-cake so pat-a-cake pat-a-cake
Baker's man so I will master as fast as
I can so that lines different Pat it and
prick it and Mark it with a tea tea for
Thomas and put it in the oven for baby
and me pat-a-cake pat-a-cake Baker's man
so I will master as fast as I can
Pat it and pick it and Mark it with the
tea and put it in the oven for baby and
me okay so now Jill is going to read I
hear a pickle
howdy Carolyn okay
who knows what a pickle is did you eat
one okay anybody else oh you know
pickles
did you eat a pickle you do oh you're
gonna like this book I think
one comes to depth my five senses I the
first one is what I hear
then should I hear in your ear
I smell right I see oh you want to sit
with me you can come sit with me you
have to pick you up
we're just taking a little break
a quick pause are you very comfy
alright there we go alright we're back
okay what's the next sense you can tell
me I touch fingers and I taste with your
mouth right
okay we first we here tweet-tweet
tweet-tweet
what makes that sound who goes tweet
tweet tweet tweet tweet tweet
Abbi that's a good guess what else
who else goes tweet tweet tweet in the
trees and they a bird good job now now
what goes cluck oohs buzz buzz buzz buzz
buzz you know Abby and what sound is a
worm make a worm
I don't think it makes any sound right
no sound for the worm okay I hear the
ocean in a shell who knows what that
sounds like
right the ocean and what about the waves
splash splash splash splash splash
splash and what about the seagull what
sound does this evil me what does it go
call that was good that was good
alright now I hear I hear grandma what
is grandma say she says hello hello on
the phone grandma says hello right and
we hear the music and we dance who knows
how to dance you know how to dance
you want to show us how do you dance oh
very good
yay who else knows how to dance he's
dancing back there what did this Claire
do you know how to dance do you know how
to do you know you don't want to that's
okay I hear the drums oh boy
thanks for visiting who knows who knows
how to play the drums a lot of drummers
lots of drummer and oh here's a good one
what about the vacuum what sound does
the vacuum cleaner me right and what
about what about like the cars what
sound do they make BP BP right Phoebe
the cars in the street Phoebe you got it
you must have heard a car before
that's right it's a what oh it was drums
yeah remember and what about what about
cats what sounded cats me they go they
go meow and they also go / right they go
/ right yeah exactly yeah I hear the
rain
who knows what rain sounds like who's
heard mean as it goes
does it go swish swish
and what about thunder thunder those
boom right boom can you do that
boom good job that's more lightning but
that's fine no no thunder what about I
hear the snow falling what does that
sound like I don't think there's any
sound no sound right there so what about
cheering cheering yeah yeah now we go to
smell
with your nose right I smell the soap
who knows what soap smells like smells
nice and clean I smell mommy's perfume I
smell my blankie do you have a blankie
who has a blanky that they sleep with no
one oh very good
oh you have a blankie I smell the baby's
poop who has a baby who has a big you
have a baby
where who has it where are the babies
there's a baby
where there's another baby right there
there's a baby there's a baby there's so
many babies
there's one who has a big brother a big
brother shoes stinky sneakers
pinky speakers
I smell I smell toast
who knows toast she eats toast bread who
eats bread bread move what do we move on
to another book all right
I'll skip some we're gonna go straight
ahead to Oh see see see with your eyes I
see the airplane where's the airplane
outside right where's the airplane is it
up yeah up right I see I see the lamp
where's the lamp right here but are
there any lamps in this room there's a
lamp right there it's dark oh there's
there's oh the airplanes right there
what about I see my books where the
books here are the books right here
I see the books right oh hi
it's okay you can say yeah you can sit
okay oh thank you
I see where's the moon where's the moon
in the sky is it in the sky
is the moon in the sky hi
should we keep skipping are we done yeah
all right one more last one I touch
what do you touch with your hands right
your fingers I touch I touch the doggie
how do you touch the doggie you put the
doggie like this
that's a doggie like that
oh here's a good one I touched the
cupcake
who likes cupcakes you do what about you
yes what about you
yes likes cupcakes you like cupcakes you
do all right last one
let's do the pickles all right who knows
pickles
all right Jim dude can you taste the
pickle what does it taste like sour very
good right and what does it feel like
when you touch it with your visit
slippery yeah
it's slippery all right I think we're
done with this book it's the end yeah
thank you for helping me read it are we
reading this other book or now no oh
they're getting wet okay so we have
another another action run from mother
Goose fingerplays and it's goes here we
go up up up here we go down down down
here we go backwards and forwards
here we go up here we go down downtown
here we go backwards and forwards here
we go round round round here we go up up
up here we go down down down here we go
backwards and forwards here we go round
round round me oh okay let's do our
Twinkle Twinkle song so get your little
twinkles going twinkle twinkle little
star how I wonder what you are so high
like a diamond in the sky twinkle
twinkle little star how I wonder what
you are
all right so now we're gonna say good
Bob it's just the opposite of our hello
song so goodbye in sign is just a little
wave okay so same thing goodbye friends
goodbye friends goodbye friends and then
it's time to say goodbye goodbye friends
goodbye friends
goodbye predators it's time to say
goodbye
all right thank you and goodbye to our
friends out in the net thank you